is from The Daily Mail
Meghan Markle is considering a run for
office
the former Duchess of Sussex
the biological weapon that I think was
made in an American laboratory somewhere
as a bioweapon to destroy the British
crown we just sent her over there like a
heat-seeking missile she found Harry and
then tried to blow up the monarchy
anyway she
could theoretically maybe be considered
to be picked I don't I don't buy it but
Meghan Markle is apparently gunning for
it Meghan Markle has reportedly
cultivated a lot of political contacts
on the left she's close friends with
Gloria Steinem the first first lady of
feminism in the United States Gloria
Steinem huge force in Democrat Party
politics
a friend of Gloria Steinem has said that
Gloria has been introducing Megan to
pivotal people within the party
according to this report Megan is
interested in politics more than
anything else and that's where she
believes her power is but she said to
focus on making money
this story this really
puts monarchists in a tough spot doesn't
it
there are there are some people in
America who are monarchists who are just
open a valid monarchists and they're
usually very buttoned up very
conservative sort of people and this is
now the best shot to get a royal into a
position of power in the United States
maybe that we've ever had and it just so
happens that the Royal is this awful
American actress who is seems
ideologically opposed to monarchy and
tries to destroy it and is a big lib I
don't know what the monarchists are
supposed to do here puts them in a very
very
difficult
spot also an amazing journey this woman
was an actress
she became a princess
but she didn't want to be she didn't
want to be the real thing she didn't
want to be an actual princess she wanted
to leave being a princess to pretend to
be a princess on TV but then she didn't
want to just play pretend on TV she
wants to be in Democratic politics what
an amazing journey of dissatisfaction
that I assume will just never
end because it's a feature of modern
liberal life that you're just never
satisfied with your station in life
right now text knowledge to 98 98 98
last month the group of 20 the G20
announced a plan to impose digital
currencies and digital IDs on their
populations Central Bank digital
currencies essentially allowed the
government to track every purchase you
make officials could even prohibit you
from purchasing certain products and
easily freeze or Seize Your Money
concerned Americans are diversifying
their assets into physical gold with the
help of Birch gold if you want a
physical asset held in a tax sheltered
retirement account you should call Birch
gold too text Knowles kwles to 98 98 98
and they will send you a free info kit
on gold the easiest way to become a
Birch gold customer is if you have an
IRA or 401K from a previous employer
just Gathering dust Birch gold can help
you convert it into an IRA in gold and
you don't pay a penny out of pocket text
Knowles Canada wlas to 98 98 98 claim
your free info kit on gold
then call them because if digital
currency becomes a reality it'll be nice
to have some gold to fall back on right
now 98 98 98 text Knowles there is
someone running for president against
Joe Biden right now who seeks to take on
not only the Republican party but
corruption within the Democrat Party
how's he going to do it
Bobby Kennedy Jr alludes to his future
plans
hi everybody I'm going to be in
Philadelphia on October 9th to make a
major announcement at the very
birthplace of our nation I'm not going
to tell you right now exactly what that
announcement will be I can say though
that if you've been waiting to come to
one of my public events this will be the
one to come to
I'll be speaking about a sea change in
American politics and what your part and
my party is in that change a lot of
Americans who had previously given up
any hope that real change would ever
come through the American electoral
process have begun to find New Hope in
my candidacy and I understand the deeply
thought concern that people have about
the way corruption
has overtaken our government it's in the
executive branch it's in Congress it's
in the leadership of both political
parties and so some people feel the kind
of cynicism alongside the hope or they
lose hope entirely because they've been
disappointed so many times I want to
tell you now what I've come to
understand after six months of
campaigning there is a path to Victory
there is a path to Victory and that path
to Victory is going to be running third
party presumably that is presumably he
might surprise us but that is probably
what this announcement is
which is Raising some concerns on the
right
because there are some people on the
right who have spent the last six months
building more than that the last year
or more building up Bobby Kennedy Jr
who is a liberal he's a basically
amiable liberal he's clearly an
intelligent man
but he's a big lib that's why I've never
been all that gung-ho about the Bobby
Kennedy candidacy is I think okay he's
good on kovid he was one of the few of
us who early on called the covid
nonsense but he's wrong on abortion and
he's wrong on guns and he's wrong on a
lot of aspects of our constitutional
order and he's a big lib so I'm not
gonna I'm just not gonna support him not
saying he's the worst guy in the world
I'm just saying he and I have very
different priorities but there have been
a lot of conservatives who have really
taken a shine to Kennedy
because one he was right on covid two
he's taking on Joe Biden and the enemy
of my enemy is my friend and three I
think there are still a lot of
conservatives who
are basically kind of liberal they just
think the left has gone too far
you know they say I I was a Democrat and
I didn't leave my party my party left me
and all this woke stuff and all this
weird sex stuff it's gone way too far
so I can't go all the way with those
radicals or I can't be a socialist or I
can't be like an AOC but I'm still kind
of a Democrat and so they long for the
days
of a Kennedy you look even at the way
that Bobby Kennedy is dressing he's
wearing those nice skinny ties from the
1960s he's trying to evoke his father
and his uncle John F Kennedy
and that that time before the Democratic
party had gone completely insane still I
think this hurts Democrats more Bobby
Kennedy is still polling it something
like 19 in the Democrat Party I think
once the reality of his political
positions comes out
I don't think that the likely Republican
nominee Donald Trump is going to have
much of a hard time prying back the
types of conservatives who sort of like
Bobby Kennedy back from him back toward
Trump and so all all in all
I'm I'm kind of for it I think that if
if
Bobby Kennedy is going to be a third
party spoiler in this race I think he's
going to be more Ralph Nader than he
will be Ross Perot I think he's going to
hurt the Democrats more than the
Republicans probably but it remains
an open question boy what a great clip
that was now
make sure that you ring that Bell
subscribe to the Michael Knowles YouTube
channel we'll see you next time